so where does the cyber seniors program
stand now are your sisters still
involved and how many volunteers do you
have
my sisters are in college right now so
when they're home for summer holidays
they do go back and teach seniors
lessons so they are still involved
but for now what we're trying to do with
the cyber seniors program is encourage
other students to bring this program to
their own communities so we have
resources on our website uh downloadable
handbooks that you can use as like a
teaching guide
and yeah we're just trying to encourage
other people to do exactly what my
sisters did it's not that difficult to
kind of call around your community
figure out
who
wants these types of programs retirement
residences libraries who have senior
citizens looking for these types of
lessons and you can just rally up your
friends and go in and teach them
so how many volunteers did you have in
the beginning you said what was it 20 or
i think we had about 20 students in the
beginning of our film
and we had about 30 senior citizens and
now where does the program stand in
terms of volunteers in the retirement
residences that we are working in i
think there's about five students in the
retirement residences oh okay
and then so so this cyber seniors
program is this
then started through sort of your
website and then people then download
all of the packages to take into their
area is that how it is yeah so we're
providing resources but other websites
provide resources as well for example
aarp has a program called mentor up
so we're partnering with them they're
sponsoring a few screenings of our film
to promote their own program and it's
the exact same idea it's young people
mentoring older people to learn
technology